most people know josh kushner as the
younger brother of former president
trump's son-in-law and advisor jared
kushner or even as the son of new york
city real estate mogul charles kushner
who spent some time in prison nearly two
decades ago for witness tampering tax
evasion and campaign finance violations
he's also married to supermodel carly
kloss but josh became the first kushner
ever to make forbes billionaire list
this year thanks to his success as a
venture capitalist which is largely
flown under the radar outside of the
industry josh founded his venture
capital firm thrive capital in 2010
shortly after he graduated from harvard
business school where he did some angel
investing and caught the attention of
venture capital firm general catalysts
co-founder joel cutler who convinced
josh to start his own fund and vouch for
him when he did
cutler in general catalyst ended up
seeding thrive's first five million
dollar funding around in 2010 and
introduced josh to other investors
helping to get the young thrive off the
ground so over the years thrive has
invested in some of the most high
profile startups of the last decade
including robin hood slack spotify and
even kim kardashian's shapewear brand
skims but his best investments may have
been an instagram and digital payments
firm strike
way back in 2012 when thrive was still a
very young firm josh muscled into
instagram's competitive series b funding
around alongside venture capital
heavyweights like sequoia capital
investing in the company at a 500
million dollar valuation just days
before facebook acquired the social
media company earning josh's fund a
quick 100 percent return then in 2014
thrive actually led a 70 million dollar
funding round that valued strike at just
over 3 billion which is a lot less than
the 150 billion plus that stripe was
valued at in the secondary market
transaction last year goldman sachs unit
peter show partners invested an
estimated 120 million dollars in thrive
last may in return for what we estimate
to be a three percent stake that would
value the firm at 3.6 billion dollars
and we figured josh was about two-thirds
of thrive leaving him with a 1.9 billion
dollar stake after we applied a
conservative 20 private company discount
as there always are there have been some
bumps along the way for josh he actually
founded a health insurance company based
around obamacare shortly before his
brother and former president donald
trump entered the white house and after
pivoting away from its obamacare-based
business model the company actually went
public at a valuation north of seven
billion dollars in early 2021 but by the
time forbes finalized our list of the
world's billionaires this march the
company's market capitalization had
created to under 2 billion
leading thrive which now holds josh's
stake with 20 ownership of the company
forbes has heard from founders like
spotify's daniel eck and instagram's
kevin systrom that josh is a hands-on
investor that really understands the
startup journey and they really
appreciate that that's allowed him to
get into some highly competitive deals
and so thrive continues to grow just
this february it raised eighth and
largest funding around to date at three
billion dollars after raising two
billion dollars in the funding round a
year earlier and its total assets now
stand at around 16 billion dollars while
josh has never played an active role at
kushner companies his family's real
estate business just last september he
his wife carly kloss and their newborn
son moved into a 43 million dollar
penthouse in new york city's puck
building which is owned by kushner
companies and also home to thrive
capitals headquarters so i think it's
fair to say that for josh his family and
his business are never far away from one
another
you